Luther schnapps Luther bread and of
course Luther's Bible Luther is
everywhere Wittenberg is celebrating its
most famous former resident and Luther's
influence has spread across the globe to
foreign countries like Tanzania and
Korea but how did the simple monk
trigger such seismic change grasped the
spirit or the mood of the time
everything he said and thought was in
the air
and what was needed was a great voice a
voice like a trumpet and the gift of
being able to fascinate people this is
what came together in Luther countless
variations of a picture went around the
world the iconic image of Luther nailing
his 95 theses to a church door in
Wittenberg the protest that led to the
founding of a new church back in present
day looking back a big 360-degree
panorama depicts key moments of Luther's
journey it took the artist yadegar
Assisi six years to create this artwork
which is 75 meters in circumference and
15 meters high
the Lutheran spirit did not only take
over Germany it spread across the world
in Tanzania Lutheran services are held
between 6:00 and 7:00 a.m. every morning
with over 6 million believers the
country holds the biggest Lutheran
denomination in Africa and the second
biggest in the world in South Korea the
Protestant church has called for peace
talks with the communist north and
affront to the state doctrine just like
Luther it is challenging the powers that
be Luther's legacy has not only been
kept alive for five hundred years it has
shaped the world
you